Humans have been playing sports for thousands
of years, with injuries and sometimes even
death being expected.
But when we look at the physical consequences
modern athletes endure, what is the most dangerous
sport in the world?
If we simply look at who gets injured the
most often, US hospital data - collected by
the CPSC in 2016 - found that for males, football
and soccer cause a significant proportion
of injuries, while for women, soccer and baseball
almost top the list.
But the number one sport for both sexes was
basketball, with 190,453 injuries for men
and 34,707 for women.
A study of injuries among NBA athletes over
a 17 year period found that lateral ankle
sprains were the most common, while a separate
study found that those who wore shoes with
air cells in the heel were 4.3 times more
likely to injure their ankle - so you might
want to ditch your Nike airs.
But minor injuries can happen for any sport
and hardly deserve the title of most dangerous;
take curling for example, which has a higher
injury rate then speed skating and luge.
Or snowboarding, where 8% of injuries take
place when loading or unloading off the ski
lift - as the lifts are actually designed
for skiers.
Luge, which involves riding a sled laying
on your back at speeds up to 150 km/h will
put you at a 40% risk of injury, however only
4% of those injuries result in missing more
than one day of practice.
So what about...death?
In terms of fatalities, a report by the National
Center for Catastrophic Sport Injury Research
found that between 1982 and 2016, the most
fatalities in high school sports came from
football, with 133 deaths.
However, that rate is 0.39 per every 100,000
individuals, given that football is the most
popular American sport.
Regardless, sports like football and hockey
often rank as some of the most dangerous sports
because of the constant collisions and hits
at top speeds, leading to a variety of injuries
including concussions.
In fact, autopsies of many former athletes
have revealed that they had chronic traumatic
encephalopathy or CTE; a disease that people
with multiple head injuries can get.
It leads to weakness in the lower limbs, hesitancy
of speech, unsteadiness, mood problems and
difficulty thinking.
These are the result of brain atrophy and
deposits of protein in the brain.
And brain injuries are actually the leading
cause of death from sports.
This leads us to the actual most dangerous
sport, which when considering all factors,
turns out to be a combat sport.
And while you might be thinking of Mixed Martial
Arts or MMA, it turns out that boxing is actually
the most dangerous.
The University of Alberta, using medical data
after matches, found that although 60% of
MMA fighters sustained injuries vs 50% of
boxers, MMA injuries were less severe.
7% of boxers had either loss of consciousness
or suffered serious eye injury during fights,
compared to only 4% of MMA fighters.
The study attributes this to MMA style fighting
which involves hitting various areas of the
body whereas boxing focuses on the head.
And boxers seem to present worse symptoms
of CTE than even athletes in football.
This is likely because of the rotational force
of hook punches, compared to the linear force
in football, which may make the brain trauma
worse.
At the end of the day, a punch to the head
during a boxing match can range anywhere from
650-1100 pounds of force making boxing arguably
the most dangerous sport in
the world.